foreign
s us up next in Ann Arbor Michigan Rick
welcome to the show
oh thank you so much for having me on uh
I listen to your show all the time and I
also uh looked at his daughter's uh
YouTube oh yeah Rachel Cruz show
well thank you so much Rick how can we
help today
uh been a fan for many years my daughter
recommended you a number of years ago so
you helped her too anyways uh I'm 76
years old and I'm 97 000 in debt
my income is four thousand dollars
okay where does the income come from
uh two from mine and my wife's Social
Security
and her uh a retirement pension okay and
that adds up to four thousand dollars a
month
yeah and she's been working part-time
and I've been trying to work part-time
so our total expenses are a little over
ten thousand a month
total expenses what is that coming from
the debt the debt interest
credit card yes so so is the 97 000 all
credit card debt
uh
it's your head down here
97 000
is uh debt
and I just had it down here and my
battery ran off oh there's about a
little under 50 000. of credit card debt
what's the other types of debt
uh let's see I got it
my truck is 675.
What's the total loan on the truck
uh 18 933 okay do you know what it's
worth by chance
uh well with the mileage on it it's
probably worth about that okay I've got
almost 300 000 miles on it all right
that that still leaves us another what
twenty nine thousands or so in debt
what's the other debt you got the truck
the credit cards what else
uh I got my wife's car
okay what's left on that loan
you take him
is it more than the truck three three no
three thousand ninety two dollars oh
okay
and there's still a whole bunch left
there on top of that George you got to
walk you through the debt snowball we
got to figure out these cars as well
yeah Rick number one I it's not gonna be
fun or easy but these cars need to go
it's one of the only kind of reversible
debts you have on this list because we
can't sell the credit card debt back to
the company but we can sell these cars
and potentially get out of a chunk of
this
my truck I use for work you got the
truck on what are you doing for work no
extra income I haul uh recreational
vehicles
I drive to Indiana pick up an RV from
the manufacturer and take it to dealers
all over the country but that any truck
can do that it doesn't need to be a
twenty thousand dollar truck right
well it has to be a big truck I've got a
Ford F-350 and Diesel that's what I I do
understand that I think the bigger issue
is what's a better line of work for you
uh where where we're not having very
difficult because I I've got extreme
health problems I've had two different
cancers I've had a heart bypass I've had
carotid bypass
but calling all this equipment across
state lines that feels like a heck of a
lot of work for a guy in your shape then
well no I'm just driving I can do that
all right well and then my wife she
needs hers for work
well I still think we need to sell these
cars and get cheaper versions that we
can pay cash for that's the bottom line
because there's not a lot of wiggle room
here we're not going to make you know
triple the income
and let me let me ask a follow-up here
is that Rick is the 4 000 a month income
that includes the Social Security Plus
you and your wife working part-time jobs
no okay so it's more than four thousand
yeah we've been we've been we've been
scraping up to ten thousand
uh okay so you're saying you have ten
thousand monthly expenses you're making
up the gap of six thousand dollars with
your part-time work together
yes okay all right that's a little bit
different actually actually I say it's
not you know mine is really not part
current part-time yeah you know I go all
the time okay all right the picture has
changed for a couple weeks yes so
they're scraping 10 grand a month
together so now the question is how can
we get we've got to reduce expenses yeah
I mean I want you guys to be able to
retire Rick isn't that the goal
to not have to do this anymore
yeah so I'm going to be 77 in January
and uh just this past month my wife came
up with breast cancer
now she's out of work but to me that
that changes the whole picture Rick I go
what needs to be true for us to be able
to retire for us to take care of
ourselves and deal with these health
issues and that means I'm sacrificing by
getting rid of these cars that have debt
on them and if that means I get a real
old truck that still gets the job done
or even changed my line of work I'm
gonna be willing to do that because
you're gonna need to be home pretty soon
to help take care of your wife it's
going to be hard to be on the road all
the time
do you have anything Rick that you can
sell
do you have other assets that you can
sell that we would have to change your
life in retirement accounts savings
accounts
no no actually we're worse than broke
our bank account is 980 in the hole oh
my God and the bank's been working with
me they're not charging me to you know
nsfd so I do have a boat
but I've been trying to sell it and
what's it worth
uh probably about ten thousand
three on it I would definitely sell the
boat make it more attractive you know
drop the price a little bit to get rid
of that debt plus come up with a little
extra cash I would hope to sell the boat
right now and pay off the boat and then
pay off your wife's car
all right that's that's a start now we
got some momentum how would that feel I
want you to just take yourself there how
would that feel if you did that with one
with one sale
I'd feel pretty good well that's a start
and as you keep doing that you're going
to free up more and more of these
payments which means that 10K can go a
lot further and help you knock out other
debts but Rick this is an emergency
situation we've got to just sell
anything that's not tied down to as much
work as we can and you're 76 I mean now
is the time to start the best time to
plant the tree was 10 years ago the next
best time is today and so let's get
about the business of cleaning this mess
up because for 76 years we've been
having a good time buying boats but now
it's time to go we want to retire we got
to take care of our health and we can't
live like this anymore